[Music]
[Music]
he is going to be dangerously hot today
temperatures are even going to be higher
than they were yesterday
[Music]
temperatures are set to soar to 37 or 38
degrees Celsius in some parts of Germany
just try to cool down and it's too hot
it's too hot is ice-cold you know Europe
is sweltering well this summer has been
marked by wildfires droughts and
record-breaking temperatures
this isn't a story about counter-strike
[Music]
[Applause]
this isn't a story about a championship
team overcoming the odds to win it all
sliding in yo girls the ends like this
is a story about five friends who dared
to reach for greatness and came up short
fans are here fade away Jordan nothing
Gilbert it's not your chance all right
this is a story about how at a time when
North American counter-strike seemed
like a joke
one summer redefined what was possible
[Music]
cloud9 had a tumultuous 2014 which ended
with an early exit from dreamhack winter
and after internal disputes
fan-favorite and a longtime member eco
what the team it's so long ago now seven
knows but we were having personality
clashes not just with him but everyone
and that lineup was kind of just like
initially like just not vibing there's
something weird about issues that
wouldn't have been there fitting a
public role so we decided after that guy
hey let's try to like chisel these roles
a little bit better and bring someone in
who we felt like in vibe well it's us
cloud 9 came out of a series of roster
samples with ibuypower skadoodle and a
relatively unknown freakazoid on the
team Scott and freakazoid were the final
pieces they fell into place alongside
shroud sean gares and nothing and filled
the gap the team had struggled with up
to that point the team was vibing well
from the get-go and we got the entry
Factory wanted which was now doing us
two clear-cut roles of Sean chat calling
and supporting means trout kind of like
playmakers off of the off the aggressive
player who is now Ryan and skadoodle who
would just obviously be that defensive
offer and actually in the clutch it was
a lot of times me and God or a shroud
and Scott who are just kind of those
people who rely on the women to be exit
the truck once again they're smoked off
jumping on top of each kills pig on the
nothing but skadoodle flicking onto one
gonna stop the bomb carrier with a
double candy get the triple he's looking
for this peak gets the flick at a nitro
as April turned to may and may turn to
June the summer of 2015 in LA was
getting hot as hell like 86 degrees in
the shade beaches were busy traffic was
jammed and the boys of cloud nine were
takedowns on paper this roster shouldn't
have worked but this iteration of cloud
9 was a classic example of district
personalities blending together into a
recipe for success you had Shaun gear
the lovable igl who'd been with cloud 9
since the very beginning nothing
who's upbeat personality matched his
aggressive play shroud the mechanically
gifted Canadian kid
freakazoid the jack
entry Fragger with a golden smile and
skadoodle disabilities with the off were
all inspiring so we had a really good
mixture because everyone was eating each
other out we had like two quiet people
in skadoodle and shroud and we had to
like loud people in nothing and
freakazoid and then I was kind of like
the one that kind of kept a lot of
people in check and made the quieter
people calm a little bit more we had
that like extremely good mixture where
it always felt like the atmosphere was
pretty good whenever we played matches
or whenever we they were practicing
despite the noise this talented roster
generated without even playing a game
North American counter-strike was still
more or less a joke no team from the
region had ever made it to the grand
finals of a major and anaise other top
team iBUYPOWER had just been banned for
match-fixing
despite the personalities clicking
behind the scenes things weren't so hot
on the server
cloud9 debut to a group stage exit from
gfinity spring masters - the boys came
back to california in need of a game
plan cloud9 had a lot of talent but they
needed to figure out how the individual
pieces fit together we started
practicing a lot and basically like we
went in this insane online mode I think
we played like 60 matches in something
like 30 days it was incredible the
amount of matches we played and our
record in the 60 matches we won like 90
percent of thing
and yeah you could say like North
America wasn't great at the time but it
was also a ridiculous run we were be
clear-cut number1 team in North America
around the same time that the boys of
summer were coming together as a team
csgo was exploding in popularity it was
the perfect storm
but heading into the ESL pro league
season one finals cloud9 were faced with
some of the toughest competition CS had
to offer and oh yeah the LA heatwave
followed them to the pro league finals
Germany was experiencing one of the
hottest summers in recent memory
we are absolutely roasting you saw
semanas sweaty brow beforehand and we
are basically we're enjoying some ice
creams about 38 degrees right now you
guys are lucky
look at those this record heat German it
is yes nice fun I mean I have AC vents
and we're just sitting here like water
in our faces everyone's counting on my
armpit hair
can you can you a desk up with some
cloud9 vests I think that is something
you attire if you go we per have to ship
them to you man because you guy don't
want these mine smells like a word I
can't say right luckily the boys in blue
still had their tank tops handy after
dominating the group-stage
c9 proceeded to wreck team enemies from
the quarterfinals and then did the same
to CLG in the settings covered off does
get flashed out doesn't get vision
finesse manages to come through gets
himself a second but scoot doodle is
there a goose to cover them off finesse
the last man standing in game leader
canny threw it for cloud nine for will
they be in the final
just one last play GG well played coming
out already it's scheduled it finishes
it then cloud 9 will move to the final
is simple to zero in the end over CLG
the finals saw them face off against the
undisputed number one team in the world
I would almost say for the fest in
Europe as you could list for many of
those maps this has just been a massacre
in the end on
cache which walls cloud lines map choice
are they're gonna try and push on
through their already got the turret
sets up a Olaf wants to go all the
information you need that grenade being
tossed out will do some damage but this
is just fantastic closing out in style
smoke is gonna go off and cronic she's
gonna put up a very good gradient
they're gonna walk right into it the
full op Molotov to burn it up a little
bit more damage and Shawn goes down
there's JW what the kill is stopping
grateful fanatic they've done it time
and again to major championships and
here it is
they are your victors here at ESL esea
pro league season 1 that loss against
fnatic kind of stunk because it felt
like we should have won like we had so
much momentum you know we we had all of
the crowd it felt like we had everyone
behind us you know like even though we
were in Europe it felt like people loved
us for some reason even though we hadn't
really shown anything yet we were just
such an underdog story at that event
when we lost to them yeah definitely
stung a little bit you know like but the
fnatic at the time was so dominant so to
play them that close was definitely like
something that we really were really
happy about at the time I remember cloud
9 went home with their heads held high
and looked to continue their hot streak
and yet another heat wave this time at
ESWC Montreal after this heat and
Cologne from last week like this is a
breeze right it's just heaven halt the
Sun is like that's only 25 degrees
despite long delays caused by overheated
servers they cruised through the
tournament and booked it another trip to
the finals where they fell to a surging
Navi well we'll see they are pushing up
and he just goes for it aggressively
sprays down two and as huge well played
Sean sees they're gonna be able to take
him down but then flamey returns with a
double of its own it's a 2v2 and flame
he gets a triple kill and now it's all
on shroud he is 17 seconds and he goes
for the fight he goes down
and now you're gonna win in 1614 and you
can tell the impact on foul line there
oh wow
battered but not broken cloud9 boarded a
plane to Spain six days later for the
face at stage 2 finals for the third
time that summer cloud 9 destroyed the
group stage before beating fnatic 200
and setting up a showdown in the finals
against team solomid these could play
very heavily into this reset exactly
right because there it is nothing gets
forced out into the open great use of
incendiary so far by TSM but a good shot
there by shroud to take the fray off of
the high heavens if it's falling as well
shroud huge round from the man in
question the man on your screen right
there
but now roasting alive skadoodle the
defence and it's down to sean gares one
before cant see chat making the mistake
the fight stop this game cloud nine were
faced with their third chance to win a
tournament in three months it's all
about keeping the cool at this point
there it is nothing trying to spring the
trap he's not gonna get it done shroud
now the last night alive he will get
collapsed not by the remaining players
for TSM and now life gets pretty
difficult for him he's got the
five-seven but he bungles the smoke and
well they don't need to give this to him
there's one peak by Cajon but now the
crossfire will be established here by
TSM device and debris the last two alive
and they will be afraid
not to be denied three times they made
the finals and three times they failed
cloud9 ended the summer as perennial
runners up and the winds of change were
blowing we were in a very hard spot
right because we had that tournament and
then we had to go home for like a little
bit after a six-week run in Europe or
like all pretty much I guess Europe to
Montreal back to Europe and then we had
him like a few weeks if I remember
correctly to prepare for the major but
we boot camps in Cologne for like a week
or two it's like everyone was just so
drained at this point at the time if you
were a talk to your human counter-strike
this crazy schedule was considered the
norm burnout was and still is real and
no matter how tight-knit you are as
friends and teammates eventually
something's gotta give and eventually
something did it's shrouded freakazoid
the last to arrive here shroud trying to
get something done here but the smoke
blocking them off an upper dark this is
burning valuable time they don't have a
kit on cloud nine they have to hit the
shots at their lifetimes but it's not
gonna happen Michael it takes out one
triggers all right there to take out
that is but it is not meant to be 1613
and kinguin will be moving on into the
playoffs they have now become a
legendary team cloud 9 midnight cloud 9
bombed out of ESL one cologne tying for
ninth and ending their final streak we
always felt like we didn't quite get
where we want to be even when we've
talked about it to this day from that
summer like we just were like each final
we are like some aspect of the way from
like feeling in control of it we had
more potential than we showed even with
all those like second places and our
team had a pretty special group of guys
is that what we're alive didn't get to
defeated like we definitely were upset
when we lost rounds but we're definitely
excited to play together and
unfortunately towards the end we didn't
lose a little bit of that excitement I
think that was part of why our
performances started getting flatter but
overall we definitely
even that now some data to talk about
like doing we had a lot more potential
we didn't truly manifest as summer
turned to fall and the weather began to
cool cloud 9 continued to win her first
Chong gear stepped down as igl and
eventually left the team in November
shroud retired to pursue a career in
streaming freakazoid left for echo fox
and nothing took over his igl for a
while but eventually even he left only
skadoodle stuck with cloud nine and
suffered even more hardship before
eventually paying it all off by winning
n A's first major as Pao biceps a push
up
you're chopping
they weren't the favorite they were the
under thought they were a heavy on the
thumb but a fitted for North America
scooters don't wanna be shocked if the
Boston a major was the pinnacle of cloud
nines presence in cs:go these five
friends laid the groundwork years early
if they had one even a single
championship we'd be remembering them
for their incredible run for their
in-game accomplishments but instead you
remember this team through a wider lens
through their goofy antics and the weird
way this summer it can bring us together
oh shut up cookie
Jesus follows this kid we remember them
for showing us that North America was
capable of competing with the best long
before we really deserve a spot on the
international stage but most of all we
remember them because we celebrate more
than just results because sometimes the
attempt is just as beautiful as a drink
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]